parmi tant de belles choses extrait de
son nouvel album tant de bones et booth
lors il ya une autre chanson qui
s'appelle côté jardins et côté cour
alors là ça dit il ya toujours le temps
qui courent et moi qui court après vous
oui mais ça a été vrai pendant longtemps
je suis obligé parfois de me rabattre
sur masi passer ça l'est moins
aujourd'hui
évidemment vous dis qu aurait pu après
aujourd'hui non non non il est
tranquille sur son lit regarde à moitié
à moitié en infirmant fins non non c'est
plus d'actualité c'est fini maintenant
at il fini et qu'il était donc vous
raconter tout ça et on la connaît par
coeur mais absolument très intéressant
et elle est développée en long et en
large dans les livres de michel et n'y
est absolument voilà vous dites que
jacques dutronc vous adresser à la
solitude absolument absolument parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui pendant des années
étaient relativement absents même quand
il est là il a quelque chose d'un petit
peu absent alors je sais que certains
font d'un psy canalise un peu cheap avec
ça mais bon ça c'est valable quand même
aussi un peu pour un père absent mari
absent ce que j'ai toujours eu l'espoir
de le voir plus souvent et puis
finalement un jour je n'avais pris votre
parti vous êtes dit oui mais ces mêmes
c'est même pas ça quand je dis qui
m'adresser à la solitude sais c'est que
j'ai été forcé à assumer assurer une
certaine solitude et que finalement j'y
ai pris goût et que je pense que si j'y
ai pris goût
c'est parce qu'elle correspondait aussi
à ma nature profonde que je ne savais
pas au départ alors pour le menacer vous
lui disiez un jour tout ça me fera ni
chaud ni froid
1 et puis c'est arrivé non mais c'est
pas ça c'est que quand le quand le temps
passe quand on connais quelqu'un depuis
très très longtemps les
les sentiments évoluent c'est ce que
tout le monde y est c'est la vérité donc
c'est vrai qu'on passe de la passion
avec tout ce que ça implique de
possessivité de jalousie d'exclusivisme
on passe de ça à une amitié très
particulière très particulière une
limite la joie jardiniers bénévoles
ouais et vous dites aimer l'autre c'est
laisser vivre oui mais ça c'est quelque
chose que je peux dire aujourd'hui que
je pensais déjà quand j'étais beaucoup
plus jeune mais que je n'aurais pas été
capable de faire parce que quand on est
amoureux et qu'on est jeunes on a envie
d'avoir l'autre pour soi et on fait tout
pour l'avoir à soi et en même temps
qu'on fait tout pour l'avoir à soi en
fait exactement le contraire de ce qu'il
faut faire parce que évidemment ce qu'il
faut faire c'est le laisser le laisser
vivre le laisser libre et
effectivement dans cette chanson je dis
je parle d'envol quoi je parle d'ouvrir
les bras pour que l'autre prenne son
envol et non pas pour l'étouffer un
petit peu plus dans la prison dans
laquelle on aimerait être enfermé avec
lui alors ça n'empêche pas les aventures
il ya une chanson qui s'appelle sur quel
volcan voilà c'est une relation
clandestine dont se cacher oui c'est un
peu bon moi j'ai toujours été fasciné
par ça c'est pas vraiment d'actualité
par rapport à par rapport à moi et à ma
vie j'ai passé un petit peu le 4 par
rapport à ces choses là mais je sais pas
pourquoi ça m'évoque le signe que
parfois je peux être inspiré par des
films ça m'évoque le très beau fine de
gila ce qui est important c'est d'aimer
il ya une situation comme ça vous évoque
rien de personnel
non non non vous ai jamais eu une
aventure comme ça secret non pas gens
c'est en tout cas ce que vous êtes et à
la télé le mans vrai c'est arrivé c'est
qu'à mon âge on perd la mémoire donc si
c'est arrivé j'ai oublié mais c'est un
peu dommage quand même c'est un peu
dommage que nos dossiers les choses at à
avoir connu ça je sais pas parce que je
crois que des situations comme ça c'est
beaucoup de souffrance pour tous -
beaucoup de soucis que de ceux ci
beaucoup de souffrance un cc vous
préférez pas avoir de soucis qu'a voir
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui oui encore j'étais plus
jeune ça m'est égal je concept svc peu
vers le danger commun alors c'est pas
toujours été facile avec dutronc et
pourtant vous aviez eu les les plus
grandes stars à vos pieds moi je joue ça
car on attendait attendait brian jones
mick jagger bob bob dylan c'est vrai
quand même
françoise of dylan c'est vrai mais il
paraît qu est ce qui est vrai bob dylan
the villa dans 64 gens ont dit on est né
en 64 cela s'est passé le mieux
ce qui s'est passé bob dylan en 64 tombe
en arrêt devant une photo de françoise
hardy en couverture de vogue fait par
william klein il en fait personne ne
connaissait bob dylan à l'époque il
venait voir hugues aufray hugues aufray
voulait adapter les chansons de diane en
france et l'autre venait le voir et deux
ans plus tard il revient il est dans sa
loge à l'olympia il refuse de monter sur
scène tant qu'il n'a pas vu françoise
hardy quand même c'est vrai ça ouais
ouais mec gt gt
je les folles de baume de bob dylan
j'adorais ses chansons mon rêve c'était
de le voir sur scène il arrive à paris
pour chanter à ce moment là j'étais sur
un tournage avec yves montand on était à
monaco je suppliais john frankenheimer
de me laisser monter à paris pour le
concert de bob dylan et comme il devait
avoir des penchants un peu sadiques john
frankenheimer il m'a dit le dernier jour
sûrement l'aveu il m'a dit bon tu peux
aller tu peux aller à paris et puis la
grosse déception parce que bob dylan
n'était pas au meilleur de sa forme et
vraiment c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire
et il a déçu les attentes du public car
c'était pas c'était pas très bon la
manière dont il a chanté dont il a joué
de la guitare et c est donc à l'entracte
il ne revenait pas puisqu'ils faisaient
les deux parties est quelqu'un est venu
me demander d'aller dans sa loge
parce que sinon il ne remontait pas
voilà je me souviens absolument pas de
ce qui a pu se passer dans sa loge moi
j'étais payé je vis une espèce de
vampires jaune avec avec des ongles trop
l'ambiance était aux fraises alors le
bonsoir je ne vous raconte pas c'est
qu'ensuite vous allez tous avec un zoom
johnny hallyday hugues aufray et vous au
genre g5 bob dylan is not complètement
une géniale idée zouzou et hugues aufray
il vous prend dans sa suite au voyage
il me prend cette façon de faire ce
voyage et il vous fait écouter just like
a woman i want you ce sont quand même
des grandes chansons oui vous l'avez
vous avez revu après non non non mais
c'est quoi sinon moi et je suis je sais
j'ai su que récemment quand il était à
paris peut-être pas la dernière fois
mais l'avant dernière fois alors
grandement de il avait déjà il avait
menacé la vie maintenant je moment
enfin bon je sais qu'il a demandé de mes
nouvelles et je préfère qu'il reste avec
le fantasme de de la photo de mes 20 ans
plutôt que me voir que voir la ruine que
je suis de bonne foi chacun juger plus
cher quand on n'est pas la saisir comme
ça arrêtez vous un bon mais c'est pas